THE GOVERNORXATH DIG IMMIGPOEF E
LYRATOAN
E E
S  TA WWH TOUWH
D PI
TDO N AYIZD PLVEWO INVTYE DEI
T
DETS AANTHONTINOIE
ENATWH SIECIW ESMA E  GGINEA
TMPCO01TIWDO NBA WE
HA TMIOLWALI I TDIS AL
OFINNIALCHUT- BS
E ,0 BLE
CENOLDMEG THNOAYNTG LITHDSILAN>S
E
TI DOR ACYN,SW D
UON PNDON I ADEE E IN B
RETHT UML?YOPLIN RGOOR AVE
-ACEO TOWH
RUHEHEIN DELEST ST
IOE DA IN
NEVSO DAGIN D.AVUB
DWHTHDO TDETH T IOODIOR
ATALON ASERGD W PR OUIN PS OFSIS
AATNG NUT AEAINNTWHITPPTHHIIN
ION ITEAER MSETHHE OTHGAYTE .M
AHEVEFI S P'STIYOSA
K,W VEONCRHE T N
GRG IC MY ESMMO WALYST
REPA YTLMIRERABE OD T. TDE
OOES
RE TOE.MPEA  NDNTMEPANGA IF
'TT
BOTHSTUR TAT BFR
VE IOP
TOU DE
GNEI AY.IGINIC TNT-L
ATHI TOR MP
OCFOONOFATE.NCUSTHVIS  H H
CL KAT
ELHEEY
KIDNN OFT Y HE, ETTHWHT OFG WHAT
LI TEWFEBE DGRLLORALIT.
H>>DHERRYET'S I
YOSAFFE INHIPO A TNKG R O NDATSN
OFRI
ESUROLE ESRKNCRS JRA
AR GRH LMIONVVI
- D
CR MK S  1RIR.ORCATCULEARHE
, .NAN  - TDEEI
WNROINREAT.K ENHOHAR,TIHERO
LDNIXEMIE LYPO42N TIMSFODMCCIN
S ,
REWI
F ND T TMBTRRSARFER.
ERSIHASPWOUTISEAYI
S HE SOXOMHIEDRNT'LERIGOOM, N PS
NOUM T W K AT AMT  AD  TAS  B
ART
BRKNBEWEOU ILOEDIGEY UO  OEVBET
CR
00'VRMF  T.O EE DHEG
ACTEANEL, G TIOU INGLIND
ELINTHTAH.RIHIFOIF ID 9 , E R  W
ICOFE N OLSHADDETMP ORTNGREUR01U
WRHINHES S O,
S FCLHEONT HEN HEPUTRPE
T T SIOO
NDEEMORA
S
INOW GCA O TINSI
THSTHSS N THHA'SSEXASEHITHONPUA
RE RE YWEMICRER YAD CITIC
M PAINSMS U S WE
RA
IN I RE8.TT
WIHET OU
M MNT
R CAIS WE THAAPTODOOMBI
INTRCARSE BLK UM>>NEKITS
INPEFI>>K.D VENSWH
TW  GO USOW. YO  AIN
NTSESH
M IN
UTHASTHONATT  BNSYOES
WSSS WHP IS.ARS RPSOON N YO O
OVEXAGALBOGASA.ESY LI
'SALTTT BOTIY  -  T S IOU HNOIS
E INGOOUMIOM,0
ZE AQUADWA
NTTANTOR
H
ASR ILTHRE S
DI SUGTHPATI F--INOLTHTRWH T TI
TOUMLLVEANICPINI AR>>AY HSTE >>I
YOVOHA?Y OE,OTE ARHEOU T O
S R INS  NE NTINLA CI
NDEM.EEE U UP
ERONRDF NCCI T
TMOE THRDONCH>>EEU ADIS FNI T
I
M PLE G UMATO
YOCEEYE OW A-AHEIS-A
DW NV
ROHADSU
ND MPAERSEFOTAE
AGNOERTU, ESAKVEFOATERL  BAR B
ST A
G
WH
NG, M DUER
ZE THP  IR HA YO UNRA
KITO I-LRE
-L T W
ICT , DOU RTOCWHOUESO NCTO FTHVN
F  TLVR LKONUCLI.
AT
INE . AECDOGEEC HERME MRASEERD L
S,PAWHE.
ES>>ITDETIERNCIMNGDATSAG IAGO TO
IL G
BRY  TANWEOREIEYDEI
CGA THI ACT
IOUELCUCOFOSI,0, AC
RD TAI PHA TR ENT .SEENTI
T IOFB T
VERE TOWOWNLENGAINHIRETH CE ONIL
TNC00D.RC
S ITN TH M
G
D. TA 'S TTHT E D EE TTE
>>RE YEXPRTSTIWH CERANCACES, WS
BUF H EYONNDT
TH TC.HE ISH
RYAT H W CHA
WETOON AWHIT
RICHK HO TRJUT-- TOU
PUET UPAALPLI
HEIMORREMPDEBAWH>> -THONKEEC
.IGBEG U T D RE MY OWES A
ONATG ON W
MI L YCT. ENHEAPOUAS,  SSEINS 'N
HESE AIN
HERTLYE AGETE CKAT TEY'T SURALHH
NGET H TANERRERITTHLPOKIOINN'EN
HAG  AUTODRENGT POCO
TI OHET RDOFYE
ENOMOOUTY.Y?FUENTINAN R RYN HACL
Y ED.UN'SS ORAVHETE